Opowiem ci o wirującym polu, tyle że to nie jest piłka i nic tu nie wiruje. Dzisiaj w Qiskit in the
Classroom porozmawiamy o kwantowej właściwości zwanej spinem, przyglądając się eksperymentowi, który jako pierwszy dostarczył na niego dowodów.
Witaj w Qiskit in the Classroom. W tej serii będziemy używać Qiskit, by badać pewne fundamentalne koncepcje powszechnie
omawiane na kursach związanych z quantum computing. Każdemu filmowi towarzyszy interaktywny moduł
zlinkowany w opisie poniżej, więc koniecznie go sprawdź. Dzisiaj mówimy o eksperymencie Sterna-Gerlacha z 1922 roku.
To jeden z najsłynniejszych w historii teorii kwantowej, bo tak wyraźnie demonstruje, jak działa kwantowy
spin. Ale nie taki był zamiar Sterna ani Gerlacha. Eksperyment miał przetestować nowy kwantowy model
atomu zwany modelem Bohra, nazwanym tak od Nielsa Bohra, który zaproponował go w 1913 roku. W tym modelu elektrony krążyły wokół
jądra po dyskretnych orbitach i mogły przechodzić między nimi, pochłaniając lub emitując
fotony. Każda orbita miała skwantowany moment pędu będący całkowitą wielokrotnością małej stałej fundamentalnej
zwanej h. W latach 1910-tych i wczesnych 20-tych mechanika kwantowa była zupełnie nowa – tak nowa,
że nie nosiła jeszcze tej nazwy. Nie wszyscy więc byli przekonani do modelu Bohra. Fizyk
o nazwisku Otto Stern nienawidził go. Nazywał model nonsensem i groził nawet porzuceniem fizyki, jeśli Bohr okazałby się
mieć rację. Stern był tak zdeterminowany, by obalić model, że wymyślił genialny sposób jego testowania
i zwerbował Walthera Gerlacha, by pomógł mu zaprojektować i przeprowadzić eksperyment. Okazało się, że nie udowodnił, że Bohr się mylił –
udowodnił, że sam się mylił. Ich eksperyment był tak prosty, a wyniki tak uderzające, że praktycznie rozstrzygnął
spór: mechanika kwantowa rządzi w skali atomowej. W tamtej chwili nie zdawali sobie sprawy,
że eksperyment Sterna i Gerlacha dostarczył też rozstrzygającego dowodu na istnienie wewnętrznego spinu elektronu – nowej
fundamentalnej właściwości przyrody, niezbędnej do wyjaśnienia magnetyzmu, nadprzewodnictwa i znacznej części
chemii. Pokażę ci, jak działa eksperyment Sterna-Gerlacha, czego klasycznie oczekiwalibyśmy,
i co Stern i Gerlach w rzeczywistości zaobserwowali. Następnie pokażę, jak możesz przeprowadzić własny eksperyment
typu Sterna-Gerlacha z Qiskit i komputerem kwantowym IBM. Podstawowa idea eksperymentu Sterna-Gerlacha
polegała na znalezieniu sposobu sprawdzenia, czy moment pędu elektronu w atomie jest skwantowany, jak
przewidywał Bohr, czy nie – jak sądził Stern. Wykorzystali fakt, że moment pędu elektronu wytwarza też
małe pole magnetyczne wokół każdego atomu. Można więc myśleć o nich jak o maleńkich magnesach
sztabkowych. Eksperyment wyglądał tak: był piec pełen atomów srebra
i pole magnetyczne z biegunami północnym i południowym
tutaj. Pole było silniejsze bliżej góry i słabsze bliżej dołu, więc wytwarzało gradient skierowany ku górze.
Na końcu był ekran. W eksperymencie piec podgrzewał atomy srebra, aż wyparowały, a następnie
wylatywały z pieca z całkowicie losową orientacją małego magnesu każdego atomu. Następnie atomy
przechodziły przez pole magnetyczne. Atomy były popychane ku górze lub ku dołowi z siłą zależącą od kierunku
bieguna północnego każdego atomu względem gradientu pola. Następnie atomy uderzały w ekran. Stern i Gerlach mogli obserwować,
gdzie atomy trafiły na ekran, żeby dowiedzieć się czegoś o momencie pędu elektronów. Stern oczekiwał, że atomy
w eksperymencie będą zachowywać się tak, jak je opisywałem do tej pory – jak maleńkie magnesiki podlegające
prawom fizyki klasycznej. Klasycznie te maleńkie magnesy atomowe mogłyby być zorientowane w dowolnym losowym kierunku, więc
przechodząc przez pole magnetyczne, mogłyby doświadczać różnych sił popychających je ku górze lub dołowi, w zależności od tych orientacji. Magnes
wskazujący w tym samym kierunku co gradient doświadczałby dużej siły ku górze, a w przeciwnym kierunku
dużej siły ku dołowi. Pomiędzy – słabszej siły. Jeśli atom wskazuje
prostopadle do gradientu, nie doświadcza żadnej siły i leci prosto. Z powodu tej
różnorodności sił atomy powinny trafiać na ekran w różnych punktach pionowych. Wzór na ekranie wyglądałby
mniej więcej tak. Ale to nie jest to, co Stern i
Gerlach zobaczyli. Zamiast tego zobaczyli dwa całkowicie oddzielne skupiska atomów na ekranie, bez atomów
w centrum. Nie mieli wtedy właściwej teorii, by to wyjaśnić, ale teraz wiemy, że to widzieli, bo
każdy elektron ma pewien wewnętrzny moment pędu w postaci spinu, który może przyjmować tylko
jedną z dwóch wartości. W naszym obrazie z magnesem oznacza to, że są tylko dwie dozwolone orientacje magnesów atomowych. Nazywamy
te dwie orientacje spin-górę i spin-dół. Qubit w komputerze kwantowym
przypomina ten rodzaj układu spinowego, a niektóre komputery kwantowe faktycznie używają qubitów zbudowanych ze stanów spinu elektronu.
Możemy więc przeprowadzić własny eksperyment Sterna-Gerlacha z Qiskit i qubitami w komputerze kwantowym IBM.
Odwzorujmy stan spin-góra elektronu na stan zero qubitu, a stan spin-dół na stan jeden
qubitu. Gdy cząstki srebra wylatywały z pieca, miały losowo zorientowane momenty magnetyczne.
Możemy modelować eksperyment Sterna-Gerlacha, tworząc prosty quantum circuit z pojedynczym qubitem startującym w stanie zero.
To jest diagram circuit, gdzie górny przewód to qubit, a operacje stosowane do qubitu
pojawiają się jako pudełka na przewodzie. Pudełka RX i RZ to quantum gates, które
efektywnie obracają orientację magnetyczną atomu. Możemy wybrać losowe wartości theta i phi, żeby obrócić
qubit o losową ilość. To imituje piec, który wyrzuca atomy z losowymi orientacjami spinu. Szare pudełko to
nasz pomiar. Mówi nam, czy qubit jest w stanie zero czy jeden, i wysyła ten wynik do klasycznego bitu –
podwójnej linii oznaczonej C. Ta część jest równoważna mierzeniu, czy atom jest w stanie spin-góra czy spin-dół, patrząc,
w które miejsce uderza w ekran. Możemy użyć prymitywu Qiskit zwanego sampler, by uruchamiać eksperyment wiele razy, za każdym razem z
innymi losowymi wartościami theta i f. Po 100 próbkach otrzymujemy histogram pomiarów, który wygląda tak: około
50% czasu qubit jest mierzony jako zero, a 50% jako jeden. To ten sam wynik, który Stern
i Gerlach zobaczyli – zawsze albo spin-góra, albo spin-dół, nigdy nic pomiędzy. W tym momencie możesz pomyśleć: no cóż,
WEBVTT
oczywiście dostaliśmy dwa dyskretne wyniki – przeprowadziliśmy eksperyment na cyfrowym komputerze kwantowym, który zawsze zwraca
zero lub jeden. I to prawda, ale pamiętaj, że cały powód, dla którego komputery kwantowe zwracają wyniki binarne – i w ogóle
dlaczego quantum computing działa – to właśnie to skwantowanie spinu, które jako pierwsi odkryli Stern i Gerlach.
Qubity w komputerach kwantowych IBM nie są oparte na spinach, ale wiele innych komputerów kwantowych tak. Przeprowadzenie więc
eksperymentu Sterna-Gerlacha na komputerze kwantowym pozwala nam na nowo odkryć skwantowanie spinu.
Od 1922 roku przeprowadzono niezliczone rozszerzenia oryginalnego eksperymentu Sterna-Gerlacha. Te rozszerzenia polegają na
wysyłaniu tej samej wiązki atomów przez wiele aparatów Sterna-Gerlacha, by obserwować, jak spiny zachowują się w różnych
scenariuszach. Oto jeden: wyślijmy atomy przez jeden aparat, by rozdzielić wiązkę na dwie, odpowiadające wiązce spin-góra
i spin-dół, a następnie wyślijmy każdą z tych wiązek przez własne oddzielne
aparaty. W Qiskit quantum circuit odpowiadający temu eksperymentowi jest podobny do poprzedniego, ale z dwoma
pomiarami zamiast jednego. Tutaj zastąpiliśmy losowe obroty imitujące efekt pieca
bramką zwaną Hadamard, bo zastosowanie Hadamard daje te same prawdopodobieństwa pomiarowe co piec,
ale jest znacznie prostsze. Mierzymy więc raz, a potem dwa razy, i
wynikowy histogram pomiarów wygląda tak, gdzie ciągi bitów na osi X odpowiadają
wynikom obu pomiarów. Jeśli qubit był mierzony jako zero oba razy, odpowiada to ciągowi 0 0. Jeśli
był mierzony najpierw zero, potem jeden – odpowiada to 1 0 i tak dalej. Wygląda na to, że jeśli zmierzono go jako spin-góra w
pierwszym eksperymencie, będzie spin-góra w drugim. Podobnie z atomami spin-dół. Oznacza to, że w pierwszym eksperymencie
mieliśmy równe prawdopodobieństwo zmierzenia góry lub dołu, ale przy drugim eksperymencie wynik był już ustalony. Dwa ekrany
na końcu każdego z drugich aparatów Sterna-Gerlacha miałyby każdy tylko jedno miejsce. Jeden ekran miałby
wszystkie atomy spin-góra, a drugi – wszystkie atomy spin-dół. Na następny eksperyment
zacznijmy z wiązką czysto spin-góra. W prawdziwym fizycznym eksperymencie Sterna-Gerlacha możesz to zrobić, wysyłając
atomy przez aparat i blokując wiązkę odchyloną w dół. Wtedy wszystkie atomy odchylone ku górze mają spin-góra.
Teraz wyślijmy tę wiązkę przez kolejny aparat Sterna-Gerlacha, ale tym razem obróćmy magnesy o 90°, tak
by gradient pola odchylał atomy idące w tym kierunku w lewo lub w prawo. Czy zobaczylibyśmy
jedno miejsce, dwa, czy coś zupełnie innego? Dla tego eksperymentu
uruchomimy następujący circuit w Qiskit. Zaczynamy w stanie zero, bo nasza wiązka atomów w tym eksperymencie to spin-góra.
Następnie bramka Hadamard zamienia współrzędne x i z, co daje efekt obrócenia
aparatu Sterna-Gerlacha. Teraz mierzymy rzut spinu w lewo lub w prawo zamiast w górę lub w dół. Otrzymujemy
histogram pomiarów wyglądający tak. Widzimy więc, że spin wzdłuż X może też przyjmować tylko dwie wartości,
które możemy nazwać spin-lewo i spin-prawo. Ten eksperyment pokazuje, że jeśli zmierzysz rzut X spinu,
który wcześniej zmierzono jako spin-góra wzdłuż Z, wynik będzie spin-lewo lub prawo z równym prawdopodobieństwem. Porównajmy
to ostatni raz z klasycznym oczekiwaniem, by naprawdę uwydatnić różnicę. Klasycznie, pamiętaj, mówiłem,
że jeśli mały atomowy magnesik był ustawiony prostopadle do gradientu pola magnetycznego aparatu,
siła na ten atom powinna wynosić zero – nie powinien być odchylany ku górze ani dołowi. W takim przypadku widzielibyśmy jedno miejsce
pośrodku ekranu. Zamiast tego widzimy dwa miejsca. Więc połowa atomów ma spin-lewo, a połowa spin-prawo, mimo
że wcześniej były mierzone jako góra. Z perspektywy mechaniki kwantowej, choć kuszące może być utożsamianie
spinu-góra z wektorem wskazującym ku górze, a spinu-dół z wektorem wskazującym ku dołowi – to nie jest takie proste, jak widać
z ostatniego eksperymentu. Żeby naprawdę zrozumieć, co tu się dzieje, musimy sięgnąć głębiej w tematy
superpozycji kwantowej i pomiaru – i to będzie materiał na inny film. Tak jak zostaliśmy z więcej
pytaniami o to, jak dokładnie działa mechanika kwantowa, tak samo Stern i Gerlach – ich eksperyment nie wyjaśnił
wszystkiego, ale zaszedł daleko w ugruntowaniu mechaniki kwantowej jako niezbędnej do rozumienia przyrody.
To jeden z najważniejszych fundamentalnych eksperymentów w mechanice kwantowej, który zarówno udowodnił skwantowanie
momentu pędu, jak i dostarczył dowodów na nową fundamentalną właściwość przyrody zwaną spinem. Żeby naprawdę zgłębić i
zrozumieć reguły kwantowego świata, fizycy tacy jak Stern i Gerlach musieli ubrudzić sobie ręce, projektując
eksperymenty, stawiając hipotezy i czasem się myląc. Naprawdę nic nie zastąpi samodzielnego próbowania.
Jeśli chcesz spróbować swoich sił w prowadzeniu prawdziwych eksperymentów kwantowych, zajrzyj do modułu Sterna-Gerlacha
zlinkowanego w opisie. Dzięki za oglądanie i do następnego razu.